[Applause]
[Music]
i'm christopher hine we're here in
monterey california
i'm talking a little bit about filling
in the gap
that exists in aikido so i think most
people have a pretty good idea of what
the aikido philosophy is right so
there's still a lot of stuff to be
hashed out with that right it's not
perfect we don't
exactly have nailed down what we think
the philosophy is but we know the
philosophy has something to do with
you know maybe some kind of peaceful
martial art where the idea is to not
hurt the other person and still be able
to protect myself
and these are the kind of things that
differentiates aikido from
other martial arts systems right so
maybe not the idea of just beating the
heck out of somebody but
but instead being able to defend myself
in a way that doesn't hurt someone else
ideally so
so that's kind of the philosophy and a
lot of people talk about the philosophy
so
even if it's not completely hammered out
for you there's lots of guys you can
read
who will kind of give you a good idea of
the philosophy and on the other side
we have the techniques figured out right
so we have tons of teachers talking
about technical details of shionage or
ikyo
or uh kodagaish or all these different
things so we have tons of people talking
about what the technical details of
aikido are
the problem is there's a giant field in
the middle that exists that we don't
really know anything about
so my approach to aikido what i've spent
a lot of my time doing is trying to fill
in that
middle section right so how do we make
those techniques
fit our philosophy and why does our
philosophy need to have those techniques
so
why what's all that stuff in the middle
and through my years of working with
aikido
i found that the two connect up very
naturally and very easily
but we're missing all that middle stuff
and i was missing that middle stuff for
years
so this is going to be a short video
series just talking about what is all
that middle ground that exists between
aikido techniques and aikido philosophy
and how do we marry the two and what do
we need to do in order to get the two
together
so if you're interested in this idea
watch we're gonna
keep putting these video ups for a while
it's gonna be a short series just on
that i'm christopher hine thanks for
watching
uh